[Music]
[Applause]
Gilbert Arenas he has uh his own podcast
Gil's Arena airs live three days a week
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday 11 30 a.m
Pacific three-ton NBA All-Star and he
joins us on the program Gilbert thanks
for joining us do you want to talk bucks
or you want to talk Miami Heat first
it doesn't matter but thank you for
having me okay so explain to me Jimmy
Butler when somebody gets into and
you've been in this like uh world before
when you get into the zone
but how could the box with three great
defenders in Drew holiday Giannis and
Brooke Lopez not stop or contain Jimmy
Butler in a must-win situation
um because in his realm it's only one
defender in that um Drew holiday which
Drew holiday is too small for Jimmy
Butler
um the other two Defenders are
meaningless to his position they're
great at defending the basket and
defending big men but Jimmy Butler's a
guard he's a big guard so
um Giannis and Lopez are meaningless to
what Jimmy does so
um
there they have to just wait till he
gets to the basket for them to be a
factor on defense which he's not he's
pulling up mid-range he's taller so when
someone like him you have to put on a
longer Defender to keep him from
shooting jumpers and push him to those
big Defenders explain to me the last
play there for the bucks that if I would
have said the buck season comes down to
Grayson Allen with the ball
as the final play of the uh their season
I mean Giannis Butler picked him up he
passed it to Chris Middleton and then
Grayson Allen didn't even get a shot off
they had a time out and they didn't even
take that Gilbert yeah that's that
reminds me of the the J.R Smith rebound
right you don't know you didn't think
that you were going to get the ball and
you just end up getting it and then from
there you just blanked out
um
I don't think I don't think Grayson knew
the time right there he's just trying to
space the floor so he just got caught in
no man's land and didn't realize to
check the clock or call a time but Chris
Middleton's gonna take the shot yeah
it's it's a something like that is more
of just a team awareness thing right if
you didn't see like the playlist
development just you know that's where
um your coach supposed to call a timeout
or the star player who's paying
attention but that's that that comes
with leadership or just knowing your
surroundings in that game I don't know
if you heard Giannis after the game he
was asked is this a failure and he said
no uh can we Marv why don't you play
that for for Gilbert if he so you'll
hear the question then you'll hear
giannis's response
do you view this season as a failure
oh my God you asked me the same question
last year Eric uh do you get do you get
the promotion every year
on your job no right so every year you
work is a failure yes or no no every
every year you work you work towards
something two hours ago right which is
to get a promotion to be able to uh take
care of your family to be able I don't
know
um provide the house for them or take
care of your parents you work towards
ago it's not a failure it's steps to
success Michael Jordan played 15 years
won six Championship the other nine
years was a failure
that's what you're telling me
no I'm asking you a question yes or no
okay exactly so why you ask me a
question it's a wrong question there's
no failure in sports
what do you make of that Gilbert
I I understand the question and
um Giannis
um
they're both they're both writing what
they're trying to say you know is it a
failure
yes in sports it's a failure because you
are the number one seed
you know during regular season your
number one seed into the playoffs and
losing to the AC is a letdown it is it
is failing for what you what you're
supposed to have been doing this year
um so yes it's it's a failure but in the
honest explanation for just the general
thought of sports no it's not a failure
because you get better every year and
yeah I get it but did Jordan fail those
other nine years he didn't win a title
well when Jordan was in a position to
win championships he didn't actually
fail the other years his team wasn't
good enough to to win championships
right so you know if we're talking about
if the 90
um the 96 Bulls lost yes that would have
been a failure yeah um Golden State 73
win that was a failure
um because you are clearly the best team
in basketball and you didn't make it out
of the first round but
um
but Gianna's explanation yeah it's it's
he's technically right also so it's one
of those is depending on the narrative
we want to run with it depends on who's
right yeah I think I think giannis's
definition of failure is different than
most athletes because of where he's come
from what he's achieved it you know he
grew up in a different type of world and
he may not look at this as life or death
but if if LeBron could you imagine if
LeBron bowed out and they were the
number one seed
and you asked the question was this a
failure
how would LeBron answer that
um
he probably would have accepted it
um on a chin
um and would he have said it was a
failure yes I think so yeah okay yeah I
do too um you know just like dirt when
Dirk lost to the We Believe team you
know he didn't even want the nvp trophy
um because it is a letdown but you can
see
that you can see it on giannis's face
that he he knows that you know this was
a failure but you know he can't accept
that for the rest of the city like you
know we have to build we have to keep
going we can't win them all and you know
it was a way of expressing his
frustration you can see it talking to
Gilbert Arenas three-time NBA All-Star
and you can listen to his podcast part
of the underdog content network
available on YouTube the I Heart Radio
app and everywhere podcasts are heard in
your Prime how would you deal with Dylan
Brooks if he was chirping at you like
he's been chirping at LeBron
um the same way in the in the indie star
player that has the ultra green light
um anytime you can get him isolated on
the island by himself you're gonna make
sure he's you know
um engaged you're gonna try your best to
make sure that is a um a rough night for
him but you don't want to you want to
play differently though he was trying to
get LeBron to play differently and say
you know I don't respect you unless you
put 40. now you're a scorer
that's different
your job is to put 40 on him yeah Mike
that that is my job to to make sure he
gets that but you're still under the the
team scheme because it is the chess
match and he's losing it to LeBron
because LeBron is not possessing that
all right I'm gonna prove you wrong I'm
gonna I'm gonna win this game and then
talk trash you while you're sitting home
since we are the lower c yeah but this
is the mature Gilbert Arenas if you're
26 and Dylan Brooks is doing this to you
what happens
oh I'm trying to score 50.
listen we try the same thing with LeBron
when when he was younger and he gave us
every possible number he can possibly
give us I would just make him shoot oh
okay and he's just attacking the whole
time I will make him pass
12 assists 30 something points still you
know so so we we've we've poked that
bear and we didn't like the way he
growled back
uh the Lakers can look really good and
then they can look really average and
last night A.D had a great game
LeBron didn't and now you go back home
and even though you're up 3-2 I mean
this is a must-win situation
uh how do the like the Lakers can be
frustrating because you think they got
it right and then they don't get it
right
right it's weird right it's it's just
when you're looking at the rest of the
superstars Jimmy Butler carrying a team
even Giannis when he was healthy playing
in the series MB you have Booker over
there just dominating and then you have
the Lakers and you're like like every
other game like our Superstars are like
taking days off
um no one is like putting they're not
willingness this series and that's what
scares me but
I've seen LeBron and I know when he when
when it's go time he goes so I'm not
worrying about you know tonight's game
um well tomorrow's game I'm not worried
about the the the next game because I
know LeBron LeBron is going to show up
so um that's that's all I need you know
that's all the Lakers need we just need
LeBron to show up and I don't it's not
going back to Memphis LeBron is going to
handle business at home and then you see
Steph Curry last night there are times
when Steph just I don't know why he
needs to remind us but he does remind us
of just how incredible he is
listen I he's just one one I remember
when
2014-15 season I remember calling um
ex-teammate Laurent prophet and I said
man listen I shot a lot I shot a lot how
many shots is he shooting this is
ridiculous this was then like I seen
I've seen the greatness in the style he
was shooting I was like how many shots
is this man shoot in a day because I
shot a lot and I don't think my shot was
like that
um
his creativity his style his his thought
process his his knack for hitting tough
shots is just unreal it is it is on it
is unreal
um
you can be a shooter but a shooter that
has the the the concept of
every shot I take is a great shot
knowing Spacey knowing time knowing the
spots on the floor knowing the angles is
just something that there's not a lot of
shooters that had that him and Clay both
possess the same thing okay but Steph
can get his shot you know Clay usually
needs help but how is it we haven't
found that Steph you know remember
Jordan uh Gerald Wilkins was the Jordan
stopper uh I don't know if anybody's
been designated as a Steph stopper why
not
um
when it comes to you know it's like
having the Reggie the Chris Mullen
um
but with Kyrie dribbling so now he can
take you off the dribble and now he only
needs this much of space so when you add
all of it together it's like it's like
giving Jordan Larry Bird's jump shooting
right it's just a whole different player
you don't expect this type of player to
have all these tangibles and Steph off
the dribble with the ball when you get
rid of the ball he's a danger so he's
he's mastered every element of shooting
to help him get open
what do you do if you're the Clippers
with Kawhi
I'll I'll try to trade him and get get
something for him but why do I want him
if you don't want him
because there's always a dumb buyer
that used to be the Knicks Gilbert but
they're they're getting smarter
it might be the Knicks you never used
you never know it's
but if a game is on the line a must-win
series he's still in the conversation
when when he's able to play of guys that
you you would take that he can win a big
series for you no when he's playing he's
greatness
um he just he just he knows how to score
he knows how to play he knows how to
will himself on on a game and on a
series but you know when you're talking
about a season and giving your chance
yourself a chance to win a championship
you can't rely on him playing enough
games to put you in that position and
then when you get in that position is
his body going to hold up yeah I know
but that's I mean he won't be there for
the season 60 games over under and now
you got Paul George
I mean
when they play they're great I thought
if they both played in the series
against the Suns I would have taken the
Clippers
because it's the Clippers you know
I guess in New York it's like the Jets
or something
they find they find ways to lose but you
know right now if I'm bomber I'm I'm
gonna be I'm gonna see if someone is
willing to give me some pieces for them
yeah um if he pans out and becomes what
we thought he was going to be then
that's just one of those
um things I just regret later on but as
of right now it hasn't panned out for us
and if why his value is still a little
hot maybe we can you know try to Will
and deal did you ever engage with
celebrities Courtside during games
no
no um um not that I can not not that I
can I mean Jack Nicholson yeah you know
Jack a little bit
um and Spike Lee you know your trip just
a little bit nothing serious though but
were you aware of who was Courtside yes
like uh you know during breaks or like
in the layup line You'll see who's there
but like you know what if there's an
actress who's there or there's you know
like Jay-Z's Courtside you're not
interested
no because they're there to see me and
you know
um no no no no
different than when I'm going to a
concert to see them their job is to
perform so
um okay when they're coming to that
Arena my job is to show them why they're
here yeah so you know it's it's one of
those instead of trying to be a family
oh my God it's Haley like yo they bought
a ticket to come see you so you have to
be off did you ever have any celebrities
with the Wizards
um we had I mean Barack Obama okay
um we had like singers like Maya
um
not a long guest list there Guilford you
know Dave Chappelle uh Martin Lawrence
um yeah so we had a lot of celebrities
Chappelle would go huh Chappelle would
go watch you play yeah okay
I like that they're Dr they're buying a
ticket to see me play yeah yeah uh hey
great to talk to you again as always
thanks for making time oh thank you for
having me that's Gilbert Arenas
three-time NBA All-Star with the Wizards
and uh as a podcast gills Arena and it's
available on Underdog content Network
and available on YouTube I Heart Radio
app and everywhere podcaster